you've talked a couple places about
maybe doing mobile games or computer
games in the future yeah yeah is that
something you're still considering yes
um because uh you know do you normally
talk with people as much as we talked
beforehand is that no no that that was
the problem we spent all day today
through my head everything you asked me
is stuff we already talked about not
really well no no not everything I take
it back but sorry the last two questions
yes and so it's just funny because what
no I tried it's okay there's a different
style of asking those questions because
I I on purpose didn't dig further would
you uh I could tell yeah so I can tell
you okay this is by the way okay all
right well this is the first time I've
ever talked to somebody
as much as I did with you
beforehand yeah on the same day we're
not even saying okay together one hour
yeah
literally it's funny
um this is a hilarious and awesome
social experiment I picked
hotel and I just like harassed him all
day to hang out with me and then great
here we are now I love it
um I was secretly recording the whole
time just you know I'm just kidding
anyway so what was the question
yeah so the interesting thing is uh with
Beast burger and feastables that um
there's physical Goods as opposed to
like making mobile games or PC game
whichever one we end up doing which is
software and I actually have a giant
International audience like
um most of my audience is obviously
outside of America and so the problem
we're running into is it just takes time
to build up the supply chain and get
feastables in Southeast Asia get
festivals in India get festivals in
Brazil and Mexico and all these other
places where we have giant pockets of
our audience and same thing with
beastware it's just it's going to take
probably years uh unless we partner with
someone who already has the distribution
which we're figuring out but the UDF
software is I can make a hypothetical
game or whatever we end up doing and all
my fans can you know use it tomorrow the
day I'm mention it and so if I promote
something in a video to 100 million
people and it's like uh you know
basically like a game they can all
download it so there you know
um but if I promote a feast rules bar
right now it's only in America because
we're struggling just to keep up with
American demand we haven't even gotten
the chance to go outside America so I I
alienate I'm a majority of my audience
and it feels so shitty to just from you
know mention something that most of them
can't buy but on the flip side you can't
just spawn this crazy infrastructure and
just have tens of millions of bars and
all your products in every single store
across the world before you promote it
so you can't put the egg before the
chicken and so
um it's like that that's that's what I'm
excited about I want to get into less
physical stuff and more stuff that
everyone audience can actually use this
is the thought process especially if
there's a social element to the gaming
too because it's not unlike feastables
like that's a product you consume you
missed it when you're setting it for
this we were uh doing some basically
just laying out every everything that
we're planning for so our interfaces
where we want to start hiring the team
to build build it and we're kind of just
laying out the game and I was actually
really curious to get your thoughts but
I can't say it because whatever I say
someone's just gonna take it and run
with it but you're pretty good idea
about the kind of games you're thinking
about yeah I mean I can imagine we also
talked a little bit about it it's super
awesome good one I did so much good talk
all right the juicy talks having you
she's like I gotta go set up well you
know I I already heard a lot awesome I
mean but that is a different kind of
team you would need to hire yeah is that
a little uh nerve-wracking like going
into a new field and trying to a little
bit but then I remind myself like like
Steve Jobs didn't know how to code right
and you know he just he just knew what a
good product was and I feel like as
someone who wasted so much of his lives
playing video games I have a good sense
of it and that might be ignorance well
that's really important right it's not
about coding it's about what makes for a
good game exactly and again that might
genuinely be ignorant so maybe I end up
you know getting bit in the butt because
of what I'm saying now but I think just
like with YouTube I just want to obsess
over making a great product and things
that I think my audience will love and I
think as long as I keep that as my North
Star will do well